on tourne
moore
inoubliable lhasa de sela a marqué
montréal et le monde avec sa musique
dix ans après son décès sa mère se
réjouit de voir cette biographie
traduite en français pour moi c'est très
émouvant et je trouve que le livre en
français c'est c'est très beau
envoûtante l'aca est le récit d'une
enfant qui a vécu avec ses soeurs une
vie de bohème à bord d'un autobus
voyageant entre le mexique et les états
unis
l'école se faisait sur la route sous
l'oeil avisé de la mer et les filles ont
étudié trois heures le matin et c'était
tout et et après elle avait elle pouvait
faire ce qu'elle voulait autodidacte
passionné par la poésie et par billie
holiday lhasa de sela a trouvé sa voie à
montréal ou de fil en aiguille elle fera
paraître en 1998 un premier album en
espagnol qui s'est écoulé à 500000
exemplaires
oui elle était toujours en réflexion
elle était toujours en un genre de
régénération de ses réflexions de sa vie
artistique
[Musique]
ce regard unique sur la mystérieuse
chanteuse a été écrit par un ancien
rédacteur au prestigieux magazine
rolling stone fait de même la préface
est signée par une amie de la sadc la
arthur ashe ladji absolument fascinante
très poétique
parce que finalement quand même la
principale oeuvre d'art c'est sa propre
ville jouer
lhasa de sela est décédée d'un cancer du
sein à l'âge de 37 ans sa biographie
nous dit qu'elle souhaitait avoir des
enfants
la chanteuse aurait bini des étoiles en
voyant qu'aujourd'hui par un drôle de
hasard
la garderie de sa nièce est situé à un
jet de pierre du parc qui porte son nom
avec les choses de la salle et a
toujours un sens et je ne mets pas en
question je sais juste d'écouter ici oui
philippe ouimet radio canada montréal
[Musique]